[Music]
macy's
is the brand long identified with the
kickoff of the holiday shopping season
and for years it's spent big to identify
its star logo
with star power almost midnight maybe
it's black friday but lately it hasn't
been
all holiday cheer and that was before
the coronavirus crisis forced it to
temporarily shutter its doors
the retailer has fared better than some
of its peers in the first half of 2020
18 major retailers have filed for
chapter 11 protection
macy's is not but the historic company
is hurting
raising questions about how far its star
could fall
[Music]
macy's first opened as a dry goods store
on 14th street in manhattan in 1858
near the turn of the century two german
jewish immigrant brothers nathan and
isidor strauss bought a controlling
interest in the company
and in 1902 they moved it 20 blocks
north to the store's present flagship
location at herald square
it became part of an upscale new york
shopping district
known as ladies mile the brothers took
the company public in 1911
on the new york stock exchange the
following year isidor strauss died along
with his wife ida in the titanic
disaster
nathan strauss continued growing the
business and in 1924 the company
expanded to take over nearly the entire
block across from herald square
and the retailer heralded itself as the
largest store in the world
that same year 10 000 people gathered in
front of its store to watch a small
procession which would eventually become
the macy's thanksgiving day parade
the company survived the great
depression and by the mid-1940s with
american servicemen returning home from
world war
ii business was booming single day
holiday sales passed a million dollars
for
two years straight which would be more
than 14 million dollars today
during the cold war the brand became a
symbol of american capitalism and
consumer choice
the store was shown off to a top
communist leader during his 1959
diplomatic visit to the u.s
before the store opens mikoyan is
escorted through macy's
for a cross-section of what's offered
the american shopper
the company expanded around the country
by the mid-1970s it had a chain of 72
department stores in 10 states
sales grew into the 1980s then in 1986
the retailers chairman and ceo edward
finkelstein took the company private
in a 3.5 billion dollar leveraged buyout
deal
and the leverage buyout loaded the
company with debt and that debt
eventually
tipped it into bankruptcy protection in
1994
federated a rival department store chain
based in ohio
agreed to acquire the brand they bought
macy's out of bankruptcy
and then you fast forward to 2005
when federated at the time was the
number one department store chain in the
country
it merged with the number two player may
department stories company
and renamed itself macy's and that's
where we get the
sort of current incarnation of macy's
inc it was
a landmark deal that created the first
truly national department store chain
with stores from coast to coast
and they had you know beloved brands uh
marshall fields in chicago
filene's they had sort of these local
brands
around the country that they eventually
did away with and renamed all the
stories macy's
battery did sought to give all of them a
coherent image with splashy national tv
ads that starred the celebrities who
sold branded products in their stores
only one star can bring all these stars
together
that's the magic of macy's it's good to
be back here at macy's
thank you all for coming i'm very
excited for my new
shoe line and then the economy tumbled
signs of a recession were in the air
between dismal retail figures and the
subprime mortgage crisis
in 2008 the great recession brought a
sharp slowdown in consumer spending
and steep losses to the company's
balance sheet the great recession of
2008
you know was challenging for all the
brick and mortar chains
and macy's in particular you know
struggled during that period
it wasn't until 2010 that macy's
returned to profitability
thanks in part to double-digit growth in
online sales by this point it operated
more than
800 department stores in the u.s for the
first time
all 800 macy's stores will open at
midnight on thanksgiving
but for the retailer and its peers the
post recession
good times didn't last long all of a
sudden
the impact of amazon and online shopping
really started to eat into their
sales and margins and traditional brick
and mortar chains woke up to the reality
that they had
way too many stores and chains like
macy's
the gap you know these beloved sort of
retail brands that were
in every mall started closing stores big
box retailer macy's is saying goodbye to
three malls
right here in hampton roads leaving a
big impact on more than 250
employees and a big heartbreak to
thousands of shoppers
the company continued cutting costs
closing stores and in 2014 it laid off
1800 workers to try to save a hundred
million dollars a year
the good news for macy's it had an
online strategy that was working
macy's dot com became the seventh most
popular online store in the us
but online sales proved to be less
profitable
you know for traditional retailers like
macy's uh
um shifting your business online
presents particular challenges online
sales tend to be less profitable
than sales in a physical store you've
got all kinds of you know shipping costs
really even to the profit margin then
came the pandemic
businesses across the country forced to
shut their doors already leading to
absolutely stunning increases
unemployment claims
all that inventory literally got locked
inside and now
it's become an aging asset inside stores
across the country
you know the country's shut down and
people aren't buying stuff
after months long closures beginning in
march of 2020
macy's posted over 900 million dollars
in losses
for the first three quarters of 2020.
despite this
it was in a better position to survive
than many of its peers
the lessons they learned from their
leveraged buyout in the 80s really
stayed with them and you know for a
retailer to take on too much debt is
very perilous this is what has pushed a
lot of
companies from jcpenney to neiman marcus
to j crew into bankruptcy to avoid debt
the retailer already had plans before
the pandemic to close
a fifth of its stores over the next
three years and on top of that
in june it said it planned to lay off
nearly 4 000
corporate staffers a macy's spokesperson
says that by reorganizing how the
company structured and reducing costs
it's in a good position to win with
customers and emerge a stronger company
not all the stores look great i mean
they've got maybe
half their fleet they've been investing
in and upgrading and
making you know into kind of marquee
locations
macy's has to find a reason to exist
why should customers come to its stores
when they can get so many of the
products
it sells elsewhere and sometimes for
lower prices
one positive for macy's as its
competitors fold
the company has a chance to pick up
market share most stores have reopened
and it's still got the annual marketing
bonanza that is
the macy's thanksgiving day parade
though in 2020
it will be a television only event
without the
in-person crowds